i'm here with emily blood give it up
[Music]
in honor of her new movie a quiet place
too which airs in theaters may 28th it's
time to play a game called a quiet case
oh
yes
i had never heard of that it was very
sexy jesse nice nice i'm going to be she
was about to do she was with the duke
just then in her head that's what she
said always
first we need hosts everybody so please
welcome the host of american ninja
warrior on nbc matt eiseman and akbar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow i like the dance moves what's up
y'all hey we are so thrilled to be here
you're doing good i'm ready to win so
how does this game go well this game is
going to be pretty good so akbar and i
have eight cases here inside these cases
are secret items now kelly and emily
will each take turns choosing a case
akbar and i will then open the case and
use the item inside of them
as quietly as possible okay
first person to buzz in and correctly
guess
what the item is okay based just
on its sound
gets the point you just do a line and
skills are allowed in this game so
okay it's time to play steals are
allowed a quiet case okay so i'm ready
here's your buddy here's the tkcs that's
kelly clarkson's show for our new guest
nice guests go first emily oh you choose
your case six i was already ready and i
was like doing anything
okay so we're not gonna don't look over
here
don't you cheat blunt
i'm known for it
i will not play a game with the cheater
all right you guys ready
you do it
we saw the light first emily you busted
in a soda
yes
great job i'm going home
in my defense i thought the noise before
the can of soda would be part of it yeah
and i was rummaging around with
something i was like is that pebbles is
that i have to try to figure it out i
would have answered a can of beer that
would have been acceptable but now
okay i am picking two
okay
oh man okay okay that's a loser number
okay
oh she's talking trash she's letting you
know the person i see blood trying to
catch a secret
i did i didn't i probably are you guys
ready yeah okay
here we go okay
whoa how did you know that so fast brush
do it again not a brush
hold on hold on
if you don't get after this you will be
ashamed
chris
oh
cheating is if you don't get it with
this
don't save me for being hungry in the
middle of an intense game
all right
here we go all right so offended by
chris emily you're up five five let's go
damn wait i see blood trying to catch me
no no no no no no no no no
all right here we go here we go
it sounds the same
brush
what is up do you have a thing with
brush no
are you okay did you brush your hair
today
don't look i can't see anything i can't
i can't
we need a guest emily
say bruh you could think of something
that was invented in outer space perhaps
sounds like pebbles or something i don't
know
is that your guess what it is it has
pebbles she doesn't know it don't give
her the point what is it what is it what
is it
what is that it's called velcro oh that
did not sound like that
the rip itself
the judge's rulings are final in the
score right now i didn't know emily two
points kelly you have yet to get on the
board
i'm sorry we're getting a report here
the judges have made a switch they're
saying this one is worth no no no no yes
five points yeah
wait it's actually kelly telling me this
i'm hearing her voice
thank you so much
thank you matt
choose your case okay oh i choose the
case you choose one because i am numero
uno
except not this because that's a brush
it would be so good if it's a brush
everything sounds like a brush ladies
are you ready everything sounds like
five points at stake pebbles whichever
one gets helps will be our champion
pebbles brushes pebbles
it fits emily
pebbles
pounding rocks kelly you need to get
this correct i want to hear again it's
not a breath okay
once again we will give you the same oh
i know what it is
can i see what it is
can i go again can i go again is it like
a
can i go again can i hear it again again
okay one second no you can't go again
you haven't yourself don't give her any
more clues because i know what it is
don't do it
here we go kevin no she's listening
carefully no she's had
enough and you cannot i cannot guess
emily blunt's voice although we are
hearing that right now i mean i heard
like a piece here we go kelly
[Music]
i will not sleep tonight if i accept
this as a win
but emily please honestly i will not
accept i did not accept this one
but still emily wins the game i'm a fair
person i'm a fair person
all right thank you guys for playing um
and you know what screw y'all for not
having a brush whatever
you can see emily in a quiet place part
two in theaters may 28th and in jungle
cruise which i'm stoked about in
theaters later this summer
[Music]
you